vote counts
i'm going to introduce our last speaker
before the senator
joins us it's my distinct honor
to introduce stephanie fellow
of the united food and commercial
workers right here at giant eagles let
it be
good afternoon everyone i'm a giant
eagle worker
i've been there nine years now i work in
the prepared food
department frying chicken making
rotisserie chicken
making sandwiches and salads selling
beer and wine
making meals
after graduating from carlow university
about 15 years ago
i went to work in a domestic violence
center
where among other responsibilities i
worked on-call
advocacy the importance of the work we
were doing cannot be
understated but i was only hired as a
part-time worker
meaning that i didn't have health
therefore
i did not get health care
shortly thereafter i lost my job
unexpectedly
about a year later i started working at
giant eagle
my starting salary was 7 35
and the minimum wage was and still is
7.25
as a part-time employee i wouldn't see
health care until my second year
to put it simply you cannot survive on a
job like that
we can't survive on 725.
[Music]
now nine years later i'm the mother of a
two-year-old son and i've got 26
000 in student loan debt
luckily for me when i've been in a pinch
i've been able to rely on my family
and my boyfriend after my grandmother
passed i was able to move into her house
rent free
let me tell you my life would not be
possible without these things
family members friends medical
assistance
this is america we deserve a living wage
we deserve health care we deserve to be
able to pay our bills
i cannot look at you all today and tell
you how i would have survived without
this external support
and the sad truth is most people in my
position
do not have that kind of support
early on in my time at giant eagle i
decided to get involved with my union
so that i could secure basic rights and
a decent salary
if not for myself for the generation
that comes after me
by bargaining we were able to secure
health care
after one year for part-time workers we
were able to secure a fourth week of
paid vacation after 12 years with the
company
we were able to secure pay raises from
that seven
thirty five to now eleven dollars an
hour starting rate
after this effort i began to look for
other ways to get involved
in the effort to secure basic rights and
dignity for workers
we marched on the boss at the south side
giant eagle
for full-time positions in our
department
we marched on the bus and they filed
charges on our union
so our union marched on the store with
drums and
people
we took an arrest with the fight for 15.
we took an arrest with the fight for 15
so that nobody has to start at 7
25 an hour
i began organizing walmart workers and
in the process
i learned about people who shared my
story
women who were forced to quit after
becoming pregnant because where
they have no light duty at walmart
that's a shame i got involved with my
union because future generations
shouldn't have to go through the
struggles that working people are facing
today
people who are working to protect their
communities deserve to have
access to quality affordable health care
people should not lose their jobs when
they have a child
and people working at a grocery store
feeding families
during a pandemic should be paid a wage
that allows them to put food on their
own table
joe biden will fight for a fifteen
dollar minimum wage
he will provide paid sick days and paid
in family leave
so that pennsylvanians can care for
themselves and their loved ones
without worrying about losing their jobs
he has also laid out an extensive plan
to ensure that people like me don't stay
awake at night
wondering how we're going to pay off our
student loans
and he will ensure that everybody has
access
to quality affordable health care
there is no one better to speak to joe's
plan for working families in western
pennsylvania better than bernie sanders
his former colleague and a leader who
has dedicated his life
to fighting for workers and families
and unions senator sanders is here today
for the same reason that we are
he knows joe biden will be the president
that working families deserve and he
like me and joe biden believe that we
have an obligation
to fight for the next generation of
working families
i'm pleased to introduce senator bernie
sanders
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello pennsylvania
what a beautiful parking lot
your cars look great and so do you
four years ago trump won the state
by 44 000 votes we're not gonna make
that mistake
again
we're going to win here in pennsylvania
we're going to win in michigan we're
going to win
in wisconsin and we are going to get rid
of
the most dangerous president in the
modern
history of this country
and we're going to elect joe and kamala
i want to thank the lieutenant governor
for being here and for the great work
that he has done and i want to thank
somali and sarah and amarado
and brian petrick and stephanie
fellow for their great work as trade
unionists
and one of the goals that joe biden and
i have
is that we know that workers do well in
the middle class
does well when we grow the trade union
movement
in america
there are millions of workers who want
to
join unions today but are unable to do
so because
of illegal corporate activity
we're going to put an end to that
now you have heard it
before and i'm going to say it again
this
is the most important election not only
in our lifetimes but in the modern
history
of our country
simply stated this country and in fact
the world
cannot tolerate four more years
of donald trump
and not only do we have to elect joe as
our next president
we need to get rid of mitch mcconnell
and we need a democratic senate
that will pass immediately
an opiate crisis legislation
that will protect the working families
of this country
it is an outrage beyond belief
that mcconnell and his friends are
refusing to vote an extra nickel
for workers who are struggling to put
food on the table
to avoid eviction to pay for health care
and here is my promise to you if i have
anything to say about it and i will
first order of business for a democratic
senate
is a major opiate
stimulus package to protect working
people
let me say to all pennsylvanians not
just progressives
but moderates and conservatives
i hope you all believe and understand
that america cannot be a model for the
world
if we continue to have a president
who is a pathological liar
you know in a democracy people disagree
with each other we'll have disagreements
but you cannot have stability in
government
if you have a president that has lied
some 20
000 times since he is
president
and we do not need a president
who does not believe in our constitution
who does not believe in the rule of law
and in fact is trying desperately
to undermine american democracy
we don't need a president who is trying
to suppress the vote
a president who is
questioning the very legitimacy
of the election in which he is competing
and has refused to say
that he will leave office
after he loses
so to all of those who have put their
lives on the line to defend
american democracy i
say that we cannot
sustain another four years
of donald trump
[Music]
and we do not need a president a racist
who is a sexist who
is a homophobe
who is a xenophobe and who is a
religious
bigot we
do not need a president who every
single day for cheap political reasons
is trying to divide us up
we need a president and that president
will be joe biden
who is bringing us together
not dividing us up
[Music]
and so at this moment this pivotal
moment
in american history we have got
to come together as blacks
and whites and latinos native americans
asian americans
gay and straight those of us born in
america
those of us who immigrated to america
we have got together and come together
as one people to show our strength
and to evict donald trump from the white
house
[Music]
most certainly we cannot continue to
have a president
who rejects science
not now not as we face
the worst pandemic in a hundred years
which has already taken the lives of
some 220
000 americans just the other day
as you'll recall donald trump told us in
the debate with job
he told us and i quote we're rounding
the corner on this pandemic
the things are getting better
and just yesterday it was reported
that we have reached the highest
level of recorded covet 19 cases
in a single day over 80
000 people new cases and over 2200
here in pennsylvania but it's not just
that trump lies about the severity of
the pandemic
what is even worse is that his
anti-science
attitude is directly responsible
for the united states having the highest
per capita death rate from covin
of any major country on earth
the truth is sad truth is
tens of thousands of americans
have died who should not have died
if trump and the administration
were prepared to deal with this pandemic
from day one as you all recall
trump downplayed the seriousness
of this horrific disease
you all remember him saying don't worry
about it it's gonna go
away well mr trump it hasn't gone away
it has gotten worse
and you can't effectively combat this
pandemic
by ignoring what the scientists and the
doctors
are saying you can't combat
this pandemic by calling dr
fauci who is a dedicated
public servant an idiot
you don't combat this pandemic
by making fun of people
who wear masks you don't combat
this pandemic by continuing to hold
rallies where there is no social
distancing
and where people do not wear
face masks that is not the model that's
not the example
we want to be showing to the american
people
in fact think about it how absurd
is it that the white house itself
has become a super spreader of this
virus
with many of the people working there
including the president
coming down with coping
you don't come back this pandemic
when six months after the start
of this horrific situation six months
later
we have doctors and nurses and people
working in
critical jobs who still
do not have the personal protective
equipment
that they need
this is a country that put a man on the
moon
this is a country that develops
sophisticated guided missiles you would
think
you might think that we'd be able to
produce
the masks that our doctors need
and now i just want to take a moment
and ask you some questions
of enormous consequences
and i want you to think for a bit about
your answers
which candidate for president has shown
that he will be disciplined that he will
be responsible
that he will do his best to protect the
people around him
as we deal with this pandemic
and the answer is
well the answer is joe bud
and which candidate for president has
made it clear
that he will develop policies which
are based on science not right-wing
politics
and that he will seek the advice of the
best scientists
and the best doctors in our country
and around the world to combat and
defeat this pandemic
and the answer is
it is joe biden which candidate for
president
will develop strong national protocols
and guidelines and model the behaviors
we all need to engage in
to keep our families our co-workers and
our neighbors
safe and the answer is joe biden
now here is a really hard one you're
ready for a hard question
which candidate has the temperament
which candidate has the temperament
to see us through this unprecedented
moment
which is in fact the worst public health
crisis
in a hundred years which candidate
has the temperament and i think the
answer to that one
is not very difficult in the white house
today you have somebody who lies
somebody who is irresponsible somebody
who has turned his back
on science and the answer as to who has
the temp
temperament is quite clear and that
answer is
joe biden
brothers and sisters as all of you know
and as you have heard already this
afternoon from the speakers who have
gone before me the crisis that we're
facing today
is not just the pandemic as serious as
that is
it is also a major economic crisis
the most severe economic downturn that
we have seen
since the great depression and let me be
very very blunt the working class
of our country today is in more
desperation right now than at any time
since the 1930s as we speak
tens of millions of our fellow
countrymen
have lost their jobs as a result of
their pandemic
they have lost their incomes they have
lost their health
insurance they have depleted their life
savings
they cannot afford to pay their rent or
pay their mortgages
they cannot buy the millions afford
to put food on the table for their
children
and my republican friends in congress
can spin it any way
they want but the truth is
that that is the reality facing america
today
today the percentage of americans
who do not have jobs is at its highest
level
in 45 years while as you have heard
tens of millions of americans who do
have jobs
are working at starvation wages
and as bad as the economy has been in
general
it has been far far worse for our
african-american
and latino brothers and sisters
unbelievably during this pandemic nearly
60
percent of latino families and 55
percent of african-american families
have either experienced a job loss
or a pay cut meanwhile and we don't talk
about
this all that often
not everyone in america
is hurting today while the middle class
is being devastated and poverty
is growing we are witnessing a
massive increase in income
and wealth inequality
and i want you to hear this because
you're not going to hear too much on the
tv
but over the past seven months
644 billionaires
not a lot of people 644 billionaires
have seen their wealth go up by 931
billion dollars
so here we are in the midst of a major
economic crisis
30 million americans have lost their
jobs
12 million americans have lost their
health insurance
29 million americans do not have enough
food
to eat 40 million americans
face eviction and yet
644 billionaires
have seen an increase in their wealth by
937
dollars
we need an economy that works
for all of us not just the few
and one of the issues that we have got
to have the courage to tackle
is this obscene level of income and
wealth
inequality in america
together we are going to end the greed
of the billionaire class
when we got a half a million people who
are homeless today
well we've got 90 million people who are
uninsured
or underinsured we are going to tell the
billionaire class
they cannot have it all
this country belongs to all of us and
not just
the few and what joe biden
and i believe is that we must create
an economy and a government that works
for
all of us and not just wealthy campaign
contributors
and i want to say a few words because i
think during this campaign
there has not been enough discussion
about what joe and kamala are actually
proposing
in terms of addressing the economic
crises facing this country and i
want to say a few words on that because
it is enormously
important number one
joe understands that a 7.25
an hour minimum wage is a starvation
wage and joe understands as i do
that we have got to raise the national
federal minimum wage to 15
dollars an hour
in the richest country on earth if you
work
40 hours a week you should not be living
in poverty
and when we raise that minimum wage to
15 bucks an hour
40 million americans will get
a well deserved pay raise
and joe and i understand something else
is that it is absurd and grossly unfair
that women in america continue to earn
70 80 cents on the dollar
compared to men
[Applause]
[Music]
it is not a radical idea by any means
to say that in this country we need
equal pay for equal work
and joe understands as i mentioned
earlier
that if we're going to grow the middle
class in this country
we have got to grow the trade union
movement
in america
and the truth is all over this country
there are workers who want to join
unions
but they're unable to do so because of
often
illegal activities on the part of their
employers
their employers will fire workers who
engaged in union organizing or standing
up for workers
rights and joe and i are going to change
that law if workers want to join
a union and if 50 of the workers in a
shop
plus one sign a card you know what they
got a union
joe and i understand that we have got to
stop providing corporate welfare
for companies who are throwing american
workers
out on the street
you cannot have a situation where
corporations shut down
plants here in america they move to
low-wage countries abroad
and the next day they're online for a
federal handout
ain't going to happen
if corporations want federal assistance
they're going to have to treat their
workers with respect
and dignity
and there's something else that joe
biden
understands that in
the midst of the worst economic crisis
since the great depression
we have got to create millions
of good-paying union jobs
brothers and sisters sometimes we forget
about it
sometimes we forget about we're the
richest country in the history of the
world
how in god's name do we continue to have
our roads
and our bridges and our tunnels
deteriorating
how do we have millions of people all
across this country
not just in flint michigan who cannot
drink the water that comes out of their
taps
how do we have a transportation system a
rail system
far behind countries throughout
the world how do we have
a major affordable housing crisis
where 19 million american families
unbelievably are spending half of their
incomes trying to put a roof
over their heads we can put
millions of workers back to work
rebuilding
america and that's what we've got to do
joe biden and you and i understand
something else that it is incredibly
embarrassing it is humiliating that the
united states of america today this
great country
only is the only major country on earth
not to guarantee
paid medical and family leave
i don't know how many of you know this
we don't talk about it too often
you go to scandinavia woman has a baby
depending on the country she may get
seven eight months off
full paid leave
and the father will get time off as well
and yet in this country beyond belief
a woman today working class woman lower
income woman has a baby
she may be forced to go back to work
next week
or in two weeks because
she needs that job to provide the income
for her family well in my view
if a woman has a baby
if a kid gets sick and mom or dad has to
stay home
we must have paid family and medical
leave
and that is why joe has proposed at
least
12 weeks of paid family and medical
leave
for working families i would go
further but that is a start
brothers and sisters when we talk about
the children and we don't talk about
kids enough in this country
you know that we have the highest rate
of childhood poverty
of almost any major country on earth
and i get a little bit tired of
politicians in washington
many of my colleagues in the senate they
get up there in front of that american
flag and they say
we love america well if you love america
you love the children
of america
and if you love the children of america
you understand
that when mom goes to work and when dad
goes to work
those children and their parents deserve
quality affordable child care
and we all know that today our current
child care system
is totally inadequate
our children and their parents
deserve better and that is why joe is
supporting
universal child care for all
three and four-year-olds in this country
[Music]
and when we talk about our children and
we talk about young people we are
talking about the future
of america it is not too
much to demand that we have
the best educated workforce in the world
child care through graduate school
it is not too much to say
that every kid in this country who has
the ability and the desire
should be able to get a higher education
regardless of his or her income
that is not a radical demand
and that is why joe believes that we
should make public colleges and
universities
and trade schools tuition free
for all working class families in this
country
and i have talked to so many young
people and middle-aged
people throughout this country who are
talking about what this
horrific and oppressive student debt
has done to their lives people are not
getting married
[Music]
so
so
so we got five days left to go in this
campaign
please bring out your friends your
neighbors your family your co-workers
let's get out and vote in state after
state this is going to be a very
close election you can make the
difference
and do it make the difference let's win
this election
for joe kamala and for all of us and
then
let us come together to make sure that
we create
an economy and a government that works
for
all not just the people on top
so let me thank all of the panels you
did a great job
uh let me thank kamala harris for being
with us tonight
and let's go forward together win the
election
transform the country thank you all very
much
[Music]
you